reject nation no sketch for this one
myself
Avengers infinity war and there's a few
other trailers we got a catch up to you
as well bye hey John yeah that's my name
that's not your name let's this watches
let's get marveled
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes that was brief oh it's brief but I
couldn't stop dude
Johar my nipples oh let me take my
Infinity Gauntlet off for this part whoo
that's a that's a that's a rigid nip my
career is in there too wow man damn look
at that big purple face I mean you can't
really comment on this stuff but I know
there are a lot of characters are gonna
be together in various scenes of the
movies where are they in the opening of
this shot where that are all looking up
and no a random space station give me a
girl's gonna be a great save the Iron
Man's firing range or kicking it with
each other oh oh and this shot right
here Thor's riding and teen Groot is
like on his phone or something what is
that armor that Captain America has this
is new like Wakanda shield so I'm
assuming that that would condo people
days mana shield yeah so they gave him a
shield right there that's what I'm
assuming special wakandan weaponry love
Tony Stark
there's a lot of things it's always
intense when Peter Parker takes that
mask off you know what are these tickets
coming out there already you know we
already have the Internet's gonna blow
up
bad day people it's gonna be like that
u2 album they're just gonna beam it into
your head look at this though Tony's
taking off the shades and it looks like
a soothe messed up I love when Tony does
something cool while he's also jacked oh
that's my favorite time for that tab
this gave us some new images and not
much new information which is exactly
what I want from infinity war no more
new information you don't let it all be
a surprising new here is that I can
count that I'll see various combinations
of characters that's exciting always
damn I love caps lumberjack look yeah
right hop that thing long hair beard
subscribe hit the notification bell and
maybe it'll work this time
get us up on the patreon where we got a
whole bunch of cool stuff like exclusive
reactions in other videos and things and
hey start us the app download in the
description box follow us first